one of my favorites who have gotten to
meet Pro Football Hall of Famer and
longtime color commentator for Seattle
Seahawks radio 13 seasons as such Warren
Moon how're you doing I'm doing great I
want to ask your question about that
horn fight now they say they're going to
Reese they're going to rescore it
donating the independent group of as I
do that then I change the result just to
make it seem like they're doing the
right thing or all due diligence the
thing I didn't understand is the group
of officials or raps or whatever or
judges that they had taking a look at
the fight independently right um they
weren't sequestered during the fight so
they don't know who whose score was
right where they did well they didn't
know they didn't know what the issue is
was about the fight oh we're doing that
they knew what the issue was
if they didn't not know that's what I'm
saying they need to be sequestered I was
wrong with boxing though that's why
people are just kind of sour on boxing
is nice as a sport it is as far as the
artistry of artistry of it right the
judging just is so inconsistent some of
these big fights and it just makes you
have a sour taste
are you gonna watch McGregor Mayweather
no you know I've never bought a fight
but I think I'm going to watch this one
just really here never you've never
bought I've watched other people who
bought it but I've never mind you've
never put hard-earned warranty turn 18
or American dollars no no but I don't
know I'm if I have to buy this one I
will buy it because it's I just want to
see what's going to happen I kind of
know what's going to happen but I want
to see how it happened I just find it
interesting that of all the fights that
you choose to not go to somebody else's
house this is the one that your Juna
choose to I would stay home and watch
this one by myself where are the other
ones I might be in a venue or a bar or
something like that watch oh wait have
you ever met a prizefighter who just
loves football or and somebody that
you've met or met a ton
like who give me give me a name is Ray
Leonard he's big sports fan in general
um Lennox Lewis is a big sports fan
believer in that I'm from Canada where I
played a little bit football so we got
to know each other represented both by
Leigh Steinberg was there never a big
price fight down and you Stan or
something down the astrodome or no but I
would go to Vegas for the big fights
like I went to Hagler Hearns I went to
Hagler Leonard I went to Mike Tyson when
he bit the ear I mean I've been to a lot
of big fight oh now I was told after
that fight I said I'd never go back to
another boy I heard I heard
after Tyson bit Holyfield's ear all holy
heck broke loose in las vegas nevada oh
it was nuts just walking around it was
crazy it really was it was it was
unsettling that's what I heard I
honestly heard that just felt like
something was going to happen but
nothing happened you know so you've
never been to another horizon I know the
big places
Warren Moon here on the Rich Eisen show
okay
so speaking of big fights how about this
is my that's my way of segue into what I
say is the biggest offseason headline
story that has nothing to do with a
draft or player or coach movement at all
and that is all of these stories that
are coming out of the Seattle Seahawks
locker room that the way that Super Bowl
xlix finished still lingers to this day
and resentment between the defense
towards the quarterback how much of this
in your estimation and your knowledge of
what's going on is is the case boring
it's not the defense against Russell
Wilson or the defense against the
offense it might be a player or two on
the defensive side of the ball they
still have a bad taste in their mouth
about it but it's almost like the movie
concussion it was a great movie as far
as what the content was because it
talked to you about concussions and some
of the things that happen but it's over
with you know
we've moved on from that and we're doing
the research and we're trying to make
improvements in the game well that's
what the Seahawks have been they've gone
through this they've moved forward but
because these stories came out people
are writing about them still even though
the team has moved past it and moved
forward
well Richard Sherman is such a major
figure on this team he has a major
figure and he has a big voice but he
clearly hasn't moved on from it the
Lauren I mean cuz Thursday Night
Football I was physically there for that
moment again the the Rams who were in
utter shambles and and they're up but
they almost
another interception on the goal line
and he brought it up again but that was
what six seven months ago they've talked
through all this this offseason they
realized it was a problem and they've
all talked about it and this offseason
that's octopus offseason do you know
where can you can you tell me sir from
players getting together at different
times a Pete bringing in guys they've
had it's been a it's been a problem
because it was something that everybody
was talking about they didn't want it to
fester anymore so they got all the
powers-that-be together and they talked
through it behind the scenes this spring
summer yeah this spring during OTAs and
all the time they've been spending
together they've dealt with the problem
and I think they've moved ahead with it
so Pete Carroll has got he got moved can
you tell me some names Richard Sherman
well the guy runs Richard of course
Richard of course Russell of course
Michael Bennett and guys like that there
are leaders on the football team they've
all talked about it you got to remember
that this team right now because it's so
young over the last two years they've
really made a lot of changes maybe
thirty percent of this team was even on
that Super Bowl team now a lot of these
young guys who are on the team don't
even know what happened or don't even
realize what the problem is so it's only
a core group of guys and had a problem
with it because those are the guys that
actually experienced it that day when it
happened but again most of those guys
have moved on past it so week one Warren
Moon Packers Seahawks second and goal
from the one
Russell Wilson Dunson hand it off to
Thomas Rawls or two to Eddie Lacy or
anybody as a running back and he's
looking at Doug Baldwin and Mike Mike
Daniels who's coming to the studio right
now sax Russell Wilson sack fumble and
it goes the other way for touchdown
nobody's gonna say anything on the
defensive side written because do you
know how many times they've thrown from
the one since that game two years ago
they've thrown from the one a ton of
times that's they've scored a few
touchdowns and they've missed a few but
they're going to continue to call the
plays that they think are best in
certain situations and you got to
execute those plays if you do everybody
says what a great call that was if you
don't then it's like what are they doing
throwing from the one they should have
ran where if sometimes you run the ball
from the one you get blasted why can
they throw the ball and they see how
many guys rip on the line of scrimmage
so you can never
be right with all the second guessers up
there how about I'm with Loren moon Pro
Football Hall of Fame and a 13 years now
in the broadcast booth for the Seattle
Seahawks Marshawn Lynch returning for
Oakland I love it it's great I can't
wait to see it I think it's going to be
wonderful and it really puts the Raiders
on considerable Superbowl footing I
believe it really does that set will his
success have any ripple effects in the
Seattle locker room seeing him do it for
somebody else should that offense be
struggling once again and marshawn's
back doing better I don't think so I
think they've moved on from Marcia and I
think we understand the great
contributions he made to the to the
organization he was the best running
backs that organization is seen big part
of that Super Bowl team but he's been a
year removed now I think the guys are
happy he's back playing and he's playing
at home I think the guys are more happy
that he's getting a chance to play back
in his hometown to finish his career but
you know we'd have to see the impact yet
he won't really have much impact on them
in the AFC as a pair as opposed if he
was in the NFC but maybe if they played
him in a Super Bowl that would be that
would be a pretty good storyline they go
against watch I mentioned a Super Bowl
Wow wouldn't that be and she at'll wins
by throwing it in from the one-yard line
or what if what if open Marshawn Lynch
laced touchdown yes that was ever that
will have a hold on it Oakland loses it
because they don't give it to Marsh
there you go and Richard Sherman is a
guy like at all how about that yes that
would be a good one football gods would
really be having a sale talk about a
Minnesota but wouldn't oh my gosh and
ran right here so key and a number of
times though that I've interviewed
people and it's not I'm not saying this
because I don't believe you I believe
every word you're saying and I believe
you believe every word you're saying and
I believe that Richard Sherman is
believing it what are they saying and so
on and so forth are you really meaning
to tell me as we're sitting here there's
nothing to see here
in the Seattle I don't love it I don't
think it's anything more to see here it
really is it I talked to Richard I've
talked to Michael I've talked to Earl
Thomas I've talked to kam chancellor
I've talked to all the leaders on the
team it's because I wanted to help them
through this thing too because you know
with things like this on teams that I've
been the quarterback position is always
going to be judged differently you're
always going to have a little bit of
jealousy on every football team because
the quarterback is treated differently
usually the highest paid player he gets
the most attention
he's never chastised in front of the
team and that's something that a lot of
players have a problem with because if a
quarterback does make a mistake you want
to hear him called out by the coaches -
that's just not the way you handle a
quarterback you handle that behind the
scenes it was the same way with me so I
understand what the players are dealing
with this team is just a little bit more
vocal than most other teams most other
teams that have this problem they'll
keep it hush-hush you know or talk
amongst each other this team will talk
publicly about anything that's going on
and that's just the personalities that
they have so who had a problem with you
when you were playing I mean what kind
of guys I'm sure but I never had a
problem where it was like me one-on-one
or something like that I mean Chris
Carter had a had a spat at the end of
one season because he was the leading
receiver in football he had he had set
the record for single-season receptions
a year before when I got to Minnesota
yeah but he said all he did was catch
touch and in the next year Herman Moore
went ahead of him by two on the last
week of the season and he said something
in the media about me not getting in the
ball enough in that last game so we got
into it and we had a discussion in
locker room but then we put it behind us
those things happen in competitive
sports do you bring that up and can't
when you see him do those things we
talked about it many times we joke about
it too but it's just something that
happened and well now you can joke about
it when you're both sitting in what
happened a real go mile there's so many
cameras on the sidelines now that yeah
there's always arguments going on
between players and coaches players and
players but you never saw it as much
when I played because now everything is
seen you can pick your nose on the
sideline and where without somebody
seeing you do it so so you got to watch
what you do today but that's always been
going on I've seen fights in our locker
room with coaches wrestling on the on
the ground in the locker room at
halftime because they weren't agreeing
over a call that was made that stuff
happens it happens in competitive sports
I want to take a break and we come back
I want names from a specific incident
okay for that specific incident and in
the television only second
about to come up I'm about to show you
the cover of Nantucket magazine that
you've heard all about and I want your
first blush on-air reaction to seeing
this magazine that features the
modern-day Lombardi as you've never seen
her cold isn't coming up large is wait
it's telling like it's coming up and I
want to talk Russell Wilson with you as
well
and all and the subject that Terrance
Knighton brought up about the NBA
salaries in relation to the NFL salaries
let's all come to it with Warren Moon
with Mike Daniels right behind him from
the Green Bay Packers here on this
Wednesday it's Wednesday edition of the
Rich Eisen show
okay Warren Moon we talked about it I
don't know how team up I might have
mentioned when we were off camera but
the magazine name Tucket magazine you've
heard about don't know much about your
vacation oh that's right I said I went
to Nantucket and you meant you mention
okay so here we go ready brought when I
took it from your desk before so you
didn't say it
Warren Moon first blush on-air reaction
to the magazine I'm about to hand to you
just get ready Warren it's everything
you want it to be Oh take it no no he
looks like a Kennedy you can open up to
date where the appeal papers over him
okay this is really Bill Belichick or
something some softer side of Bill
Belichick yeah a more human side of Bill
Belichick I bet you most people when
they think of Bill Belichick they don't
even think he does anything like this
they don't think of nantucket meadow no
dress they don't think of him in a
blazer wears a sweatshirt you know there
is no no good for him but not on a hood
with a hoodie what do you think I think
it's very tastefully done you know what
I like about what's going on with Bill
right now he's really seems to be
enjoying himself he got I agree with you
doesn't I mean interview things he's
been seen at you know he can't go into
basketball games and just seems like
he's getting out a little bit more I
think that fifth Super Bowl was probably
something in his mind as a goal it's
like okay I've done it now I can relax
and just enjoy the rest of my career you
know you think Shaun I really do I
really will that manifested a lot of
people don't know about him anyway he
has a great personality if you really
know him and I remember when I got
inducted into the Hall of Fame he sent
me a really nice letter and I heard he
does that to all the guys that go in he
takes his time because he appreciates
you know competition and he appreciates
players and we have for our fun with
this but good good for him good for you
I think is great who is the lady that
somebody in his life yet is it
somebody's life Lynda Holliday who
unbeliever one believes that the what's
the phrase that they heard Tom Brady
call out for the audible while he yelled
cougar one
Grimm in London and he does Linda right
after cougar yes that's what I've
already thought that yeah there it is
and she's older than none
that's what a hoovering day oh yeah what
go over gone over the top a little bit
[Laughter]
my fellow comm is right there for all my
listeners and viewers to go get the
special offer called the four pack
special 806 one three five nine seven
four these are the best pillows in the
market worn are they they are what
there's a lot of pillows on the market
these are the only pillows for you and
it's not on the ones that I'm betting on
another room do we have a my pillow here
we need to get one on the second is over
and I'm taking them out I haven't seen
one pretty soon today because I was up
late last night see you would have a
good night's sleep what a yes with one
of these Indians specifically made for
the type of sleeper you are you are back
sleeper side sleeper on the back side
back side sleeper it's okay at some
point it's back as employments OCI about
to sit up back so I thought you slept on
your ass and basically told me here
office well they got a pillow for you at
my pillow calm and you drop the promo
code rich or eight hundred six one three
five nine seven four Warren Moon is
sitting here in the Rich Eisen show set
russell wilson what is your relationship
with him do you do does he seek out
advice from you do you talk to him he
does you give unsolicited to sent I do
if I think there's something I need to
tell him like what give me a free can
you can you expose it for example please
after a game you know I do every game so
I see everything that he does so I might
ask him about a certain plan I'm never
criticizing but I'll ask him what were
you thinking on that throw that you made
a Jimmy Graham or whatever what were you
thinking on certain route just to see
what comes out of his mic as
quarterbacks we don't all think the same
on everything anything could happen
within a play where you might miss a
play say because somebody got in your
vision and everybody's going what the
guy was wide open but sometimes there's
a guy that gets in your face and you
just can't see that that guy was wide
open especially when you're five ten and
a half so I I like to ask questions
about what guys were seeing on certain
plays and and just kind of get his
reaction and we'll sit on the plane
sometime and talk about different things
that might have happened in a game or
I'll go over to his locker after again
the first thing I want to know is he
okay was tough you know if it was a
physically a tough game on him I want to
make sure he's okay and stuff like that
but I'm not I got to be critical but I
do like to ask questions so you're
saying are you saying that sometimes
when he doesn't get the ball out on time
which has been a major criticism of him
right from what folks at the draft I was
hearing all sorts of conversation
at the draft that they might go ahead
and draft somebody just to fire a shot
across the bow that it is time for you
to get the ball on top just like we
practiced
just like the plays are drawn up that
sometimes he doesn't do that because he
doesn't see that the balls sometime he
delivered pressure sometimes again guys
get in his face and most teams know if
you have a quarterback that's only 510
and a half you're going to try and push
a lot of pressure right up the middle of
the pocket so you do unpair his vision
and sometime he just misses some things
especially throws over the middle of the
football field does he need competition
in there no he's as competitive as can
be he really is what happened with
Kaepernick best you can tell I don't
think they ever intended on signing him
at all I think they brought him in is
like a fact-finding mission they know
him as well as any quarterback in the
league because they played against him
twice over the last what four or five
years so they know what his strengths
and weaknesses are but they didn't know
him as a person so they bring guys in
just just in case something happens down
the road say if Russell gets hurt they
want I've already had a conversation
with him to see what type of guy he is
because they might want to bring him in
as their starter you know they might not
want to go with one of their backups if
it was a se Aiye injury where Russell
was going to be out for a period of time
so now they know Colin a little bit
better because they spent some time with
him and if something was to happen to
Russell god forbid they could bring him
in just like they brought in Adrian
Peterson earlier during free agency they
weren't going to sign Adrian Peterson
but now they know if they need a running
back of Adrian was available
they come they'd go back and get him
that's just what Jon Snyder does and
Pete they kind of they take they take
advantage of every opportunity they can
looking down the road if something might
have a football Hall of Famer Warren
Moon here in studio so Peterson's gone
off the market cap Rick still is not
what do you think Colin Kaepernick is
being blackballed in the National
Football League no I don't think it's
blackballed but I think there are
certain teams that just won't have
anything to do with him because of their
stance on whatever he was doing and they
didn't maybe like the way that what what
he did with the with the kneeling of the
flag but also I think teams just don't
want to bring him in because they don't
want to deal with the repercussions of
all of that and then then there
a certain style of play that he's only
good at so that he can't go to every
offense just because the Atlanta Falcons
might need a backup quarterback he's not
a good for the Atlanta Falcons offense
he's not that type of quarterback so you
got to look at the offense that I think
he fits best into and that's where he
probably has the best chance of going
he's not a quarterback for every offense
in his league so there's you essentially
he's not being blackballed by an entire
league but there are some teams that are
doing oh I'm sure I'm sure the Jets for
one you know Woody Johnson everybody
knows about his political affiliations
and that I don't think he would bring in
a Colin Kaepernick so there's certain
owners that just won't have anything to
do with them well for those people who
think that ESPN is losing viewers
because of the political leanings
allegedly they're going to love when
Kaepernick shows up for the ESPYs
tonight as he is scheduled to be oh
really yes we got invited he's expelled
some people can still nothing more now
ten years in me and running it could be
a late invite I the mothership just just
has nothing to do they know where I live
they know where I live what do you think
of the NBA salaries that free agents
have received Terrence Knight was very
very vocal about hey how coming in if
ELLs not getting it shows like when he
was younger and about four inches taller
I'd be getting one of those contract
what a Timothy miles golf can get 67
million dollars guaranteed they have so
much money available now because they're
doing so well with their TV contracts
and that they have to spend it but play
NFL players are saying that their PI is
huge too and Mark PI is big but we also
have four times five times the number of
players of the NBA team as 15 players
you're playing and paying in basketball
as opposed to 53 guys in football so you
just don't have that much money to
spread it all around like that but I
think the biggest thing in football you
want to get more guaranteed contracts I
think that's where we need to move next
moreso than the size of the salaries is
making sure that money once you do sign
for it you're going to get it all
basketball player he's going to get all
that money when he signed yeah I what
were they Brockman I saw comparisons
about how much money that I think Tim
Hardaway
a just signed by the Knicks is making
more guarantee about even Derek Carr
well than any remaining player the
amount and instead made in his whole
career god I saw did you see that yes
tomorrow a junior yes but I mean it's
all relative I looked at when I was
playing I was one of the higher paid
guys but compared to what Carrie
Bradshaw and Roger Staubach made when
they were playing they look like they
were grossly underpaid but then you look
at what I was making back then compared
to what these guys are making now that's
just the way the game has grown and
improved you expect that to happen and
you're happy for these guys you just
hope that they appreciate why they're
able to make this type of money alright
so who are those coaches on the floor I
said at the end of the last segment that
you've seen coaches argue so vehemently
that they actually rolled around the
floor fist fighting during so my team
look at what happened every that
everybody did see Kevin Gilbride and
buddy buddy Ryan on the sideline taking
taken swipe at each other what was it
like in the locker room after that game
very intense and we won that game like I
thought hey we want you won that game
yeah we were way ahead that's what God
buddy so upset that we threw the ball
right before the half with a lead and he
thought we should have ran the clock out
well so those were not the coaches
rolling around on the floor when the
bright they didn't spill over into the
locker room though I'll just name one of
them Jerry Glanville I knew it Glanville
got on the floor with an assistant was
he the head he was he the head coach the
head coach okay it was the defensive
coordinator offensive coordinator and
another assistant on the Houston Oilers
staff yes got on the floor and get a
little tussle did symbol who broke it up
I'm not sure if I hadn't made it to the
locker room you know I just heard heard
I got in and saw the last part of it but
what what was it like with Gilroy our
head coach at the time you Campbell
young he had to kind of settle it
everybody down because he knew that
everybody was aware of what was going on
Bellator and really what that happens it
happens all the time it does in the 21st
century but last year in the NFL two
coaches fought on on the locker room
floor that I don't know if they fought
in a locker room but I'm sure they've
had fights in their meeting rooms and
then
it's a very competitive very intense
sport Wow
I kind of don't want to end a
conversation like that but I have two
Mike Daniels the Green Bay Packers is
here like Mike might have a couple of
stories for you though Mike McCarthy
it's a McCarthy and let's just make it
him and capers gone on the ground
Roger broke it up I mean what's near
them all but that was may your monster I
remember that far came right in other
words but we came up with Super Bowl 50
to ends with the Raiders taking on the
sea hauling the Raiders are on the
one-yard line they don't give the ball
to Marshawn Lynch and Richard Sherman's
are opposed interception and takes it
nine yards aflateen I get another Super
Bowl ring thank you I've seen y'all
seein can't walk alright look at the
ordinates Warren Moon here in studio
back in 60 seconds with Mike Daniels in
person of the Green Bay Packers the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you liked that video be sure
to download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches